a guy looks like stay dumb and they're
with him for 10 plus years and have kids
with them it's just a lie I'll discuss
more in a moment now back to someone
should post pictures of older guys with
money that look average or below average
and hot guys with no money to see which
ones women prefer to message on Tinder
clown world show but we know the answer
to that looks matter more than ever
because most people don't have the time
to read dating profiles and instead just
swipe left or right there's also the
fact that biology matters besides just
Aesthetics the taller and better looking
the children a woman has the more likely
the woman can use her son for survival
if something bad happens well I never
thought about that huh I never thought
about that as being an incentive for
like jeans